welcome back mississippi and texas gave
americans their power back this week
lifting statewide
mass mandates and letting businesses
fully open which really upset
joe biden i think it's a big mistake
the last thing we need is neanderthal
thinking that in the meantime
everything's fine take off your mask
forget it
it still matters i know you all know
that
i wish the heck some of our elected
officials knew it
joining me now that evil man mississippi
republican governor
tate reeves governor what is your
response to the president
well today i feel the same way as i did
the day that hillary clinton called all
of us in middle america deplorables uh
when president biden said that we were
all neanderthals uh
it struck me as someone who needs to get
outside of washington dc and actually
travel
to middle america the fact of the matter
is we are just simply doing the things
to give
our people the power back to do
what they think is best for themselves
and their family
uh your your liberal detractors will say
you're putting your folks at risk tell
me why you're not
well here are the facts our goal from
the beginning
has been to ensure that we protect the
integrity
of our health care system contrast that
with what some would
argue is that the goal should be to
ensure that no mississippian ever
contracts the virus
the fact is that's not a realistic goal
our goal is to protect the integrity of
our health care system
the facts are you cannot look at the
data
and and focus on the data when numbers
are going up
but ignore the data when the numbers are
going down at our peak
approximately seven weeks ago we had
approximately 15 000 cases
in one week a seven day average of over
2 400 cases
the fact is last week we had less than 3
000 cases
in mississippi last week the fact is
that at our peak we had 1450
mississippians
in hospital beds that number is 418
today the fact is at our peak we had 360
patients in icu beds that number is
below 120
today so we no longer have a health care
crisis in our state
and so we've got to allow our people to
make good decisions the fact is
i trust mississippians and i trust
americans
to do what's best for themselves and
their family and i wish the president
would focus on
trusting americans rather than trying to
insult americans
well as you know governor you can't
allow people to make decisions
for themselves especially when you're a
politician you got to have all the power
yourself thank you so much i think your
people will support this decision
well no doubt and look joe biden's
handlers believe in a central government
making all decisions for us
we believe in the people being able to
uh and be allowed
to make their own decisions thank you
governor